I don't like the Dawn incident because I've been through it.
Why is he here?
Little rain kid playing practical jokes
Don't you hate it if someone takes you away by throwing out your pompoms and other witches?
I think it's a bit of an exaggeration to call it number 2, but
what do you want from
me?  What is Tiger? It's a
simple thing What
you feel What you think
What you remember
I want you to
let me taste the derived fruit called the unknown What do
you think?  But when you make a contract with me,
I will definitely take you to the future you desire At the
end, the translation will always come with a pillow 3 years
.
I'm going to give you my name, but hey, you're the addendum I'm just a watchdog to keep this place
fair  Please read it from day to day